[Piano music]
[Antani] I went to school for computer engineering
in India. I've worked with image processing,
computer vision, pattern recognition, machine
learning. So, my world was filled with
developing algorithms that could extract
interesting objects from images and videos.
Pattern Recognition is a family of techniques
that looks for particular pixel characteristics or
voxel characteristics inside an image and learns
to recognize those objects. Deep Learning is a way
of capturing the knowledge inside an image and
encapsulating it and then researchers like me
spend time advancing newer deep learning networks
that look more broadly into an image, recognizing
these objects, recognizing organs in my case,
and diseases, and converting those visuals
into numerical risk predictors that could be used
by clinicians. So, my research is currently in
three very different areas. One area looks at
Cervical Cancer. A machine could look at the
images and be a very solid predictor of the risk
to the woman of developing Cervical pre-Cancer,
encouraging early treatment. Another area I work
with, Sickle Cell Disease. One of the risk factors
in Sickle Cell Disease is Cardiac Myopathy or
Cardiac Muscle Disease, which leads to stroke
and perhaps even death. Looking at cardiac echo
videos and using AI to be a solid predictor,
along with other blood lab tests, improves
the chances of survival. A third area that
I'm interested in is understanding the expression
of Tuberculosis in chest X-rays, particularly for
children and those that are HIV-positive. The
expression of disease in that sub-population
is very different from adults with TB, who are
not HIV positive. Every clinician have seen a
certain number of patients in their clinical
training. They perhaps have spent more time
at hospitals or clinical centers, and exposed to
certain population, and they become very adept at
that population. Machines, on the other hand,
could be trained on data that is free of bias,
from different parts of the world, different
ethnicities, different age groups, so that there's
an improved care giving and therefore, a
better expectation on treatment and care.
[Piano music]